one of the most interesting tricks found
in breath of the wild this year has to
be with octo balloons they allow link to
duplicate equipment and they can also
perform this anime-like energy animation
also known as active arrow smuggling
today i'm specifically covering this
trick and how to do it for yourself at
home if you like breath of the wild
content and want to keep up with the
latest discoveries make sure to stick
around here on gamespot as we continue
to cover this endless game to this day
the beginning of all these shenanigans
was first found by satogashi back in
june 2021 fiddling around with the
timing of objects attaching to octo
balloons revealed that you can use them
to duplicate items active arrow
smuggling was a secondary find so let's
simply do the trick first
all you need is magnesis elemental
arrows and octoballoons then find a wall
to back yourself up to preferably with
flat ground around you once you're all
ready cast magnesius then pause the game
and hold an octo balloon this will drop
it directly at your feet then draw your
bow as soon as possible and halfway
through notching your arrow pause again
once you've paused again drop the
equipped bow then unpause and spam a as
fast as humanly possible if you see this
congrats you've done it correctly and
you'll have a shining arrow in your hand
and the octo balloon uh freaking out
here's the whole process one more time
without any pauses
[Applause]
[Music]
now let's explain a little bit about
what happened here when you perform this
glitch what's actually happening is the
drawn bow is starting to clip through
the world disconnected from your held
arrow when the bow attaches to the
balloon the downward force of dropping
it makes it float forever downward but
the balloon is still attached to it and
is unable to clip through the wall along
with it so of course starts to go a
little nuts being stretched and
stretched further until it pops
at this point the bow is still drifting
away into the void going farther and
farther away from you this distance away
from the separated bow and arrow is what
makes this glitch work the farther you
fall away from the bow the faster this
animation becomes
so that means you'll have to wait
farther for it to float away on its own
once three minutes has passed go into
the menu and switch arrows if your arrow
disappears from your hand then you've
done it all you have to do is wait
around and it should start up
automatically on its own within the next
30 seconds or so this is active arrow
smuggling now as long as you don't draw
your bow you can walk around and do many
actions while looking awesome combine
this with your camera to get some sweet
selfies
as a bonus not only does vertical
distance away from the bow have an
effect but horizontal distance does as
well after you walk away a certain
distance it'll have this static floating
effect instead pretty neat
hopefully you learned a thing or two
today and if you enjoy videos showcasing
tricks like this let us know in the
comments below and of course if you want
to learn many other things about breath
of the wild check out our breath of the
wild expert series playlist showing new
things even to this day and for
everything else gaming stay tuned right
here on gamespot
[Music]
you